[Music]
so I think economics has a something to
contribute in terms of our understanding
of artificial intelligence because it
gives us a different view so for example
when when if you ask a technologist to
tell you about the rise of
semiconductors they will talk to you
about the increasing number of
transistors on a chip and how the and
all the science underlying the ability
to keep increasing
you know doubling number of transistors
every 18 months or so but if you're
asking an economist to describe to you
the rise of semiconductors they won't
talk about transistors on a chip instead
they'll talk about a drop in the cost of
arithmetic they'll say what's so
powerful about semiconductors is they
substantially reduced the cost of
arithmetic it's the same with AI
everybody is fascinated with all the
magical things AI can do and economists
what they bring to the conversation is
that they are able to look at a and a
fascinating technology like artificial
intelligence and strip all the fun and
wizardry out of it and reduce AI down to
a single question which is what does
this technology reduce the cost of and
in the case of AI the recent economists
think it's such a foundational
technology and why it's so important it
stands in a different category from
virtually other every other domain of
technology that we see today is because
the thing for which it drops the cost is
such a foundational input we use it for
so many things in the case of AI that's
prediction and so why that's useful is
that as soon as we think of AI is a drop
in the cost of prediction first of all
it takes away all the confusion of you
know what is this current renaissance in
AI actually doing is it Westworld is it
c-3po is it how you know what is it and
it really what it is is simply a drop in
the cost of prediction and we define
prediction as taking information you
have to generate information you don't
have so it's not just their traditional
form of forecasting like taking last
month's sales and predicting next
month's sales it's also taking for
example if we have a medical image and
we're looking at a tumor and we suite so
that what the data we have is the
and what we don't have is the
classification of the tumor as benign or
malignant that the AI makes that
classification that's a form of
prediction and so when something becomes
cheap we use you know from economics 101
most people remember there's a downward
sloping demand curve and so when
something becomes cheaper that means we
use more of it and so in the case of
prediction as it becomes cheaper we'll
use more and more of it and so that'll
take two forms one is that we'll use
more of it for things we traditionally
use prediction for like demand
forecasting and supply chain management
but where I think it's really
interesting is that when it becomes
cheap that we'll start using it for
things that weren't traditionally
prediction problems but we'll start
converting problems into prediction
problems to take advantage of the new
cheap prediction so one example is
driving driving we've had autonomous
cars for a long time but we've our
autonomous vehicles but we've always
used them inside a controlled
environment like a factory or a
warehouse and we did that because we had
to control the number of think of it as
the if-then statement so we have a robot
the engineer would program the robot to
move around the factory or the warehouse
and then they give it a bit of
intelligence they put a camera on the
front of the robot and then give it some
logic saying okay if somebody walks in
front then stop if the Shelf is empty
then move to the next shelf if that if
then but you can never put that vehicle
on a city street because there are an
infinite number of ifs there's so many
things that can happen in an
uncontrolled environment so you could
never that's why I use recently as six
years ago experts in the field were
saying we'll never have a driverless car
on a city street in our lifetime until
it was converted into a prediction
problem and the people who are familiar
with this new cheap form of prediction
said why don't we solve this problem in
a different way and instead we'll treat
it as a single prediction problem and
the prediction is what would a good
human driver do and so effectively the
way you can think about it is that you
know we put humans in a car and we told
them to drive and humans have data
coming in through the sensors on our the
cameras on our face and the microphones
on the side of our heads and our data
came in we process the data with our
monkey brain
and then we take actions and our actions
are very limited we can turn left we can
turn right we can break we can
accelerate and you would the way you can
think about it is is think about an AI
sitting in the car along with the driver
and what that AI is trying to do is it
doesn't have its own input sensors eyes
and ears so we have to give it some we
put radar camera lidar
around the car and then the AI has this
incoming data and as its every second
it's got data coming in it tries to
predict what in the next second what
will the human driver do and in the
beginning it's a terrible predictor it
makes a lots of mistakes and from a
statistical point of view we can say has
big confidence intervals it's not very
confident but it learns as it goes and
every time it makes a mistake it thinks
that drivers about to turn left but the
driver doesn't turn left it updates this
model it thinks that driver was going to
break the driver doesn't break it
updates this model and and as it goes
the predictions get better and better
and better and the confidence intervals
get smaller and smaller and smaller so
we turn driving into a prediction
problem we've turned translation into a
prediction problem now so that used to
be a rules-based problem where we had
linguists with many rules and many
exceptions and that's how we did
translation now we've turned into a
prediction problem I think probably the
most common surprise that people have is
we have a lot of HR people to come into
our lab and they say hey you know we're
here to learn about AI because we need
to know what kinds of people to hire for
our company and you know for our
manufacturing or our sales or you know
this or that division of course it won't
affect my division because I'm in HR and
you know we're a very people part of the
business and so a is not going to affect
us but of course people are breaking HR
down to a series of prediction problems
so for example the first thing HR people
do is is recruit and recruit you see fed
essentially they take in a set of input
data like resumes and interview
transcripts and then they try and
predict from a set of applicants who
will be the best for this job and once
they make and once they hire people then
the next part is promotion promotions
also being converted into a prediction
problem you have a set of people working
in the company and you have to predict
who will be the best at the next level
up job and the next role they do is
retention they have 10,000 people
working the company and they have to
predict which of those people
most likely to leave particularly their
stars and also predict what can we do
that would most likely increase the
chance of them staying and so you know
one of the what I would say that a black
art right now in AI is converting
existing problems into prediction
problems so that AIS can handle
[Music]